Brad Pitt has a new romance just in time
for the holidays the lucky lady Inez de
Ramon well you're you're in the know
Source tells E.T the actor recently
started dating the 30 year old jewelry
designer quote Brad is enjoying spending
time with Inez and getting to know her
better it is new but they are seeing
where things go and like each other
they're having a good time together when
you look at your options and you make
the best decision and you carry on
Brads were first spotted at a Bono
concert in LA last month but at the time
A source told ET they were just friends
and the relationship wasn't romantic and
now another source says that Inez is
pretty chill and private and has been
somewhat overwhelmed by the attention
she's received being photographed with
Brad ET has reached out to the Oscar
winner for comment you know usually
anyone who stands next to me usually
it's usually reported as oh well
Brad's Dating News comes after he was
romantically linked to Emily Ratajkowski
in September following her divorce
however it seemed the two called it
quits by October when the model made her
relationship status very clear quote I'm
newly single for basically the first
time in my life ever and I just feel
like I'm kind of enjoying the freedom of
not being super worried about how I'm
being perceived being someone who's in
the public eye and has experienced that
so much I really encourage people to
have a healthy
um
a little bit of disbelief of and and
wanting you know and just understand
that these these headlines are designed
for people to click on
as for anes she was previously married
to Vampire Diaries star Paul Wesley you
know if you're scared Damon you can go
uh wait outside with the three-year-olds
the pair tied the knot in 2019 but went
their separate ways earlier this year
and confirmed their split to ET in
September
well it seems like things are going well
in Brad's love life and his career the
actors closing out the year with the
star-student film Babylon when I first
moved to LA Signs on all the doors said
no actors or dogs allowed I changed that
you know day one it was like wow we're
really going for it here aren't we and
then like day three you're like okay
we're really going for it and then like
two weeks into it you're just like
just another day just another day at
work we need tea caught up with Brad at
the premiere he had to clear up some
rumors that surfaced from set including
the one that is co-star Margot Robbie
snuck in a kiss she wasn't supposed to
kiss you and she kissed you
there's room for like
uh
interpreter
and and believe me that's the tamest
thing she does in this in this she is on
fire on this
foreign